speaking of things that aren't so
awesome uh California school is going to
have to pay over three million dollars
after rejecting an lgbtq curriculum the
curriculum covered Harvey melk who is
the first uh openly gay elected official
in the United States who was
assassinated in 1978. here's the thing
about Harvey Milk he was known to have
been preying on underage boys he was in
a quote unquote relationship with a 16
year old at one point when he was in his
30s but of course children have to learn
about him in school is if he's a hero
and this District the school board said
no sorry we're not interested in
teaching our kids that so Newsome said
we're going to find you 1.5 million
dollars and force you to pay another 1.6
million in shipping costs associated
with the material that were sent to
these schools so we're seeing stories
like this all the time I'm glad to see
that the school board is fighting back
look at Newsom who claims to be the
gatekeeper and the warrior for free
speech when he's talking about book
bands and the fact that all ideas need
to be allowed out in California telling
people that they actually have to have
this curriculum forced on them when
their school board has said no we don't
want this there's a hill you have to die
on and eventually
um otherwise you keep losing and and I
think again it's hard it's easy for me
to say this because it's not my school
or it's not my my three million dollars
but the answer is no
yeah we're just not going to pay that
fine and we're not going to teach it are
you going to extort 3 million dollars
from us are you going to are you going
to shut down the school well then you
know what you shut down the school sorry
like eventually you just have to stop
giving in to this because uh if school
boards what's the purpose of having a
school board if then the governor can
just override it and then the governor
is overridden by the Department of
Education and where does it end so
ultimately it's really just Joe Biden
Joe Biden decides everything that's
absolutely right well I mean these these
people are all tyrannical and it's so
frustrating because you had Obama come
out the other day and write this letter
saying oh it's wrong to ban books and of
course the books that are being banned
here are generally pornographic they
contain materials that are scarring for
children and it's the parents who are
saying we don't want our children to see
this content the vast majority of these
quote unquote book bands are led by
parental groups and even opponents of
that will acknowledge this but they'll
say these are parents who are backwards
religious fundamentalists even though
firstly as far as I'm aware I don't know
that there's actually a strong religious
component to it I would imagine there is
just sense that we're in a country which
is based on Christian values but these
people I know some of the people who go
up and fight these school boards and
they're not all religious people by any
means so the left will try to smear
these people they'll try to smear the
Grassroots efforts to get this
pornographic content out of schools and
the truth is it's because they know
that's the only option they can't try to
blame the the usual actors the big
donors any corrupt political class for
this they can tell this is coming from
parents this is coming from families who
are saying stop preying upon our
children and I think you'll see these
tests uh going forward this idea that
you don't want this type of curriculum
in your school for what seems to be
legitimate reasons uh and so you will
have to pay a fine so you feel guilty
and so you don't feel like maybe we
shouldn't do that it's going to hurt our
kids education these tests are going to
be something that parents unfortunately
face a lot it reminds me a little bit of
this story about the school district in
Utah a liberal parent said well you I I
think you should ban the Bible because
the Bible talks about sex and the Bible
is pornographic scenes but it doesn't
and one
one of the one of the State uh lawmakers
who had been really pushing to keep
lgbtq curriculum uh and again I should
say sexually explicit uh curriculum out
of school said well if this is the price
we have to pay that's okay because I
would rather uh make sure that your kids
are protected even if that means they
have to learn about the Bible at home
and I find it interesting that we're
coming up against these tests pretty
regularly right now if we have to keep
something out what are we willing to do
for that I think a great tactic that
I've seen a lot of parents do is they
try to go to the school board meetings
and they try to read the book out loud
yes and they're stopped I think the
scientists did it at a press conference
and all the networks how to go to
commercial break yeah and that's that's
just the most valuable time if I can't
say this to you and we're all adults
here if I said these things right now
YouTube would would find Tim I mean it
wouldn't find me so I guess I can go
ahead and say them right I can drop the
F-bomb it's not my show yeah exactly
and Tim's not here
is not here who cares but I think that's
such a valuable tactic like show how
vile these things are and then and then
stop hiding behind gay people to do it
stop it's it's it's pornography don't
hide it's it's it's it's it's either
it's sexual exploitation of children
stop using gay people as your Shield
because you're a bunch of perverts
that's quite frankly I gotta say the
book we have right here I opened it to a
random page and just the first thing I
saw was like
I can't even describe it it was
disgusting it's it's really disgusting
and so genderqueer is one example of
this the other uh example we've brought
up because we actually have the book
here is this book is gay and this is a
book that is in schools and school
libraries and it actually explains how
to sign up for gay hookup apps now
here's the thing it does say oh these
apps are for adults but hold on a second
this stuff the way Smartphones work with
their interface it's not rocket science
adults can figure it out why is there a
guide on how to sign up for these apps
in schools where miners can check them
out you don't put something in a book
that a miner shouldn't know and then
write if you're under 18 don't read past
this point or this section isn't for you
and that's not how this works yeah yeah
exactly don't do it we're just gonna put
it here and let you make your own
decisions I think that's the craziest
thing that the you know the argument
that comes up and that I hear pretty
frequently is you know uh people need to
hear these things because it's we need
to have a sex positive culture and we
need to have a culture that uh you know
these issues are life and death for some
people because if you don't know you
don't feel firm this that and the other
then uh you know you're in danger of all
kinds of terrible things and of course
we want to live in a compassionate
Society but does that mean miners need
to read sexually explicit content in
schools no it doesn't well no but here's
the thing they say we want a sex
positive Society what does that mean
what does it mean what does sex positive
mean they're trying to negate the
purpose of sex by spreading perversion
by definition they are sex negative the
purpose of sex is unity and procreation
if you're trying to strip that away from
it you are negating you are sex negative
what they're really trying to say is we
want to spread perversion that's all
that's all I think we're sexualized
enough to society yeah yeah I mean
you can't watch any commercial without a
beat you can't watch any music video
minus a couple of country ones
you really can't watch much without it
being about sex exactly how much of a
pervert you have to be to complain about
the fact that there's not enough of it
out there all the time and and should we
be telling teenagers your sexual
identity is the biggest thing you should
know and identify and think about all
the time right isn't there enough
pressure as an as a young adult to come
of age and to to Grapple with difficult
life problems like do we need to say
your libraries need to be stocked with
this are you think about all the time
when really we should be encouraging
them to pursue their intellectual
passions to develop good moral character
right like there is no reason that this
should be the number one conversation
you have with your teens no matter how
you think their their orientation will
end up especially when you consider and
I hate saying this because I I don't
like to knock America I I love this
country and I love the people in this
country but I will say it bluntly
especially when you realize how ignorant
our young people are oh yeah you can say
poorly educated and they are you could
just flat out and say dumb
um like these are subjects that a we
shouldn't Broach them ever but if if all
of our kids had Straight A's and the
then the school board was like well
should we start thinking about other
things but our kids are incredibly dumb
yes like they basically what you see the
numbers 30 35 don't read it leveled can
perform math at level like most of them
can't write or read script so you you
scratch your head and say well we want
our young people to be sex positive it's
like I just like them to be litter at
first like can we just do the basics
yeah exactly and any adult who like
tells you they have this agenda like oh
yeah I want this child to be really
accepting of a lot of different sexual
things like okay why because I've said
this before in the show but we asked
this question as conservatives why do
kids need to see that that's the wrong
question the question is why do you need
to show that to a kid why are you so
invested in ensuring that a kid sees
that I think we all know no kid likes to
read about sex until they are a certain
age and it's I don't care if it's hetero
homo it doesn't matter like like they're
introducing it to children at an age
that it's so uncomfortable and it should
be uncomfortable it's healthy like a
nine-year-old should not be a sexual
being and when they say well everyone is
a sexual being if you think a
nine-year-old is a sexual being you are
a pedophile you belong in jail yeah
absolutely and you know it's different
when you're talking about especially
guys you know and they're they're
hitting their hormones and they would
read any book that's well maybe not
they'd be more interested in sex books
and sex talks but but the fact that
we're doing this with
six-year-old and seven-year-olds is just
so disgusting I would agree well evil I
just want to mention one thing quickly
even with what you're saying like when
when kids go through puberty and they
start noticing the opposite sex you're
right that they have an interest there
but that's also why you need to be even
more protective at that point and ensure
that they don't end up seeing disgusting
things that are going to pervert them
because they'll end up going see and
seeking out material and there's so much
perversion online that they'll stumble
into the solution isn't like well let's
show them the weirdest grossest stuff we
can find the solution is educate them on
the dangers of looking at pornography
talk to them about the fact that
researchers are discovering a strong
link between uh pornography and
impotence you tell you you tell young
men that I promise you that's going to
alter their behavior right people need
to be protected from these things these
things shouldn't be forced onto them but
again I think we're all pretty clear on
what the agenda is here we know why
there's an interest on the part of so
many people in this system to get miners
invested in this perverse content and it
it's telling that the reason this school
board rejected this content that
California is trying to force on them is
because it was covering uh the first
elected gay politician in the country
who celebrated by the left and viewed as
a martyr and who was exploiting and
preying upon and abusing underage boys
had had a 16 year old quote-unquote
boyfriend when he was in his 30s that's
not a boyfriend it's a minor he groomed
I haven't seen said chapter I'd love to
know what the chapter was because that's
what they're saying like this was a book
that was explaining that Harvey Milk was
killed in 19 whatever Europe
um but I guarantee you it was not that
you know and if you had a chapter of the
70s for 14 15 16 year old kids and you
talked about unrested in the 70s famous
people who were assassinated you can go
through the list you can throw his name
down because he was famous and he was
assassinated but I would love to see the
actual chapter
saying about his life because I
guarantee it was not that innocuous like
we just mentioned that he was a gay
politician who was killed I'm like oh no
you didn't thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time